Yo ! C'est Cyrus, et bienvenue pour cet épisode de rien du tout !
C'est un épisode où je vais juste, je vais vous parler parce que j'ai l'impression
que ça fait très longtemps qu'on s'est pas parlés. Alors p't'être que vous vous avez pas cette impression
parce que vous me voyez, bah, quand je fais une vidéo;
mais en fait quand je fais une vidéo c'est une sorte de personnage.
C'est toujours quelqu'un qui présente des choses et c'est pas moi
directement, et là c'est... Quand je parle comme ça,
c'est très rare mais c'est moi directement.
Quoi donc euh...
Donc je sais pas, j'avais l'impression que ça faisait très longtemps que je vous avais pas parlé
directement. Donc... J'espère que vous allez bien !
J'espère que tout va bien et tout
Je voulais vous parler de deux-trois trucs qui étaient importants.
Je voulais revenir d'abord sur ma dernière vidéo,
donc, dans cette série des candidats aux présidentielles,
et la dernière vidéo elle vous a pas trop plu,
en tout cas pas à tous.
Et au début, huum...
Au début ça m'a un peu heurté j'crois, et après en fait
bah j'ai compris, et
et j'en suis, j'en suis désolé. Ah donc c'est celle là,
et effectivement, comme vous le voyez, vous êtes 33%
à ne pas l'avoir aimée du tout.
J'pense qu'il y a eu plusieurs choses dans cette vidéo. Donc bon
alors y'a le fait qu'il y ait six candidats en une vidéo, ça
euh... Je m'en suis expliqué au début et j'aurais p't'être dû prendre plus de temps
pour expliquer pourquoi j'pouvais pas,
je pouvais pas faire autrement
avec le planning que je m'étais fixé, et que en gros...
En gros j'aurai pas pu le faire onze vidéos
du même poids pour chaque candidat, alors
il aurait fallu que je m'y prenne bien à l'avance et, genre c'est...
C'est un truc que j'ai voulu, j'y ai pensé beaucoup plus tard.
Y'a un mois où j'étais complètement à l'étranger, donc
j'étais pas en France, et donc je pouvais pas tourner ces vidéos là.Je les ai tournées à l'avance et tout,
et en plus comme c'était tourné à l'avance, j'avais pas
tous les noms des candidats qui allaient se présenter, etc.
Enfin bref, y'a eu beaucoup de raisons, je vais pas rentrer
dans le détail de chacune.
Y'a des questions donc de temps mais aussi de moyens,
parce que chaque vidéos coûte,
parce que j'suis pas seul à travailler dessus. Donc voilà y'a pas mal de choses,
mais je pense que ça à la limite, tout seul,
ça aurai pu passer si cette vidéo là
était bien faite.
Le problème c'est que cette vidéo là, bah dedans j'rigole,
dedans j'dis des choses qui sont fausses,
et vous m'avez repris dans les commentaires sur Asselineau notamment.
Et tout ça, ça a donné l'impression que je m'en battais les couilles
alors que c'est faux, je m'en bats pas les couilles.
Mais effectivement,
avec du recul je comprends totalement que
c'est ce qui se dégageait de cette vidéo,
et j'en suis désolé. J'suis désolé du coup
pour toutes les personnes qui ont pensé ça, et que ça a heurté.
Effectivement, la phase où je rigole par exemple,
bah j'aurais pu me débrouiller p't'être pour la retourner même dans un,
même si y'avait pas ce...
Même si c'était pas dans ce décor-là, tant pis ! La retourner,
au calme,
je sais pas. Je sais pas comment j'aurais pu faire mais
en tout cas ne pas la laisser comme ça dans la vidéo.
Et je ferai tout mon possible pour pas que ça se reproduise.
Pour tout ceux qui s'en battent les couilles, n'hésitez pas à continuer à vous en battre les couilles,
ça ne me dérange absolument pas. Autre truc dont je voulais vous parler,
je vous en avais parlé vite fais dans l'onglet community.
Alors je sais pas si l'onglet community tout le monde a pu le voir, tout le monde y a accès,
ou si c'est juste pour mobile,
en tout cas c'est un onglet où je peux vous poser des questions, vous parler de certains trucs, etc.
Et je vous ai parlé de cette chaîne mais j'en avais pas parlé encore en vidéo.
C'est une chaîne que je fais avec
France TV éducation, qui s'appelle "Quelle Histoire Cyrus", et en gros l'idée
c'est à chaque fois de prendre un
un concept d'actu, donc par exemple "Les Fakes News",
"La Robotisation", "La Séparation des Pouvoirs", "La Trahison" etc, plus ou moins lié à l'actu,
et l'expliquer avec un background historique et parfois philosophique, etc.
Et en fait à chaque fois j'ai un ancêtre qui vient
et Via l'ancêtre, en discutant, on apprend des trucs, etc.
Ça s'adresse
à une cible qui est légèrement plus jeune que vous
MAIS c'est fait de sorte à ce que vraiment chaque épisode parle à tout le monde,
et normalement vous apprenez un truc
dans chaque épisode. Les retours que j'ai
qualitativement sont hyper cools, donc je suis très content.
Merci à tous ceux qui me font des retours dessus,
ça m'fait vachement plaisir, ça m'touche. On est 5 965
dessus, donc n'hésitez pas à aller faire un tour, à vous abonner
et à checker les nouvelles vidéos quand elles sortent, y'en a une par semaine.
C'est un projet qui
me fait vachement plaisir parce que France TV Education bah c'est eux qui sont derrière
"C'est pas sorcier" etc. Et "C'est pas sorcier" bah c'est euuh...
Une grosse inspiration pour moi, c'est un des trucs qui a fait que
j'avais lancé le "Coup De Phil" y'a maintenant trois ans et demi...
Plus. Donc hum
Donc voilà, n'hésitez pas ! N'hésitez pas à checker et me dire ce que vous en avez pensé.
Ça me fait vachement plaisir, j'suis très fier.
J'suis désolé pour cet éclairage qui est très clair/obscur,
c'est un petit peu le côté "May the 4th be with you",
joyeux Star Wars Day à tout le monde.
Huuum
Juste pour vous dire, demain je sors une vidéo qui n'a rien a voir avec ce que je fais d'habitude.
Ahem, c'est une fiction,
c'est un délire, juste un délire.
Et enfin dernière chose, je serai au Bordeaux
Geek Festival, qui se déroule
du 25 au 28 mai, donc moi ça sera le
27 - 28, je suppose, le week end
à Bordeaux. Et je voulais aussi prendre un moment pour vous dire merci, parce que
bah c'est souvent à la fin d'une vidéo, à la va vite etc.
Là j'ai un moment avec vous donc je vais en profiter
pour exprimer ma gratitude, et donc, bah merci.
Merci d'être là, merci de, d'apprécier mon contenu,
merci de me soutenir.
Ça me fait...
Ça me touche.
Ça me touche, vraiment. Love, beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup,
et peace,
Beaucoup aussi, on en a besoin
des deux. Ciao !